yeah welcome to this video play plus
from Norway come on gimme c5 that is
Norway right yes it's become a bit
easier with Magnus but still sometimes
handsome flag problems not just with the
chess clock okay night see to that early
on it's a rare move it's not bad I think
but it's still fairly rare 93 I'm going
to take
maybe
yeah I think this is that early night to
c5 is the right recipe against this and
occasionally taking who just puts the
light in the center interesting okay
well this is not so easily developing so
here and just attack the f pawn plane
you can even consider to play six that's
nothing particularly bad one isn't that
bad but I wonder you can also think
about 85 currently cannot play the beep
horn here would be one less actually a
move that will probably happen hoop you
want to be three I wonder if I can
somehow play in some way too late to say
expect that ready myself for it i'm not
really sure them maybe this and then a
five is when be three i can take and
play 94 it's interesting drive yeah yeah
85 very likely be three psychological
reply yeah and here i was thinking i can
take and do nice before because he has
this a to porn uncovered and protect it
may I can remove that
or not yeah it's an interesting decision
here for what definitely how to take I
wasn't sure what looks right here the ti
feels fairly comfortable I get some
things traded which is almost always
good against tamiroxie and yeah here
night a 2 is a consideration I under get
the bishop and I can play 93 yeah that
would give me dark squared bishop I
guess I cannot run really let's do it I
was thinking about this is what i meant
with dark squared bishop so we have
opposite colored bishops now but my
bishop is potentially the much more
dangerous piece because his dark squares
a week oh he weakens the dark squares
even more surprisingly okay it's so not
[Music]
easy to exploit he might want to bring
the night over to be five that's
possible Queen d6 it's kind of the
obvious move but if he gets Knight to c4
what should be five this is going to be
tough to break down I would definitely
like to trade the slight not easy to do
I wonder if my light on this album is
actually a good piece maybe I should we
rooted somewhere that's not an if I
expected not at all actually equipped
looks a bit weakening I mean there's
some logic to it once I'm remove if it
looks annoying how does it cover that
should be 394 is unsettling for white I
would assume a stock of a certain mr.
covers everything it's not such a big
problem okay
yeah okay 94 doesn't really do all that
much okay but I don't really think if
I've is a d5 is always under pressure
and then I can take all right him yam
bit of a sudden end to the skin yeah I
thought originally I thought that here
should be quite in quite good shape but
it wasn't that great I mean my bishop
indeed is better than his but the
problem is that this is a 4 is a good
move that just makes it very difficult
to do anything I was thinking he just
remove the night from c2 to be five and
then just it's basically one place on
the Kings side it's possible that this
is looking nice but not doing all that
much very much possible can t nobody
should be 14 that would have been good
engine like that and the night will come
to see 493 yeah this is not such a
comfortable position I mean I thought I
should be ok but that term I really am
from here I have to try to improve
somehow i'm not quite sure how exactly
you six buy a stock fish is an
interesting trial and not something that
I call about
hmm yes probably just roughly equal ok
guys thanks for watching